I don't know if you can see this photo I
know you're familiar with the photo but
it is you when you are in the hospital
bed the Snapchat filter tell me the
story of this photo from your point of
view that photo wasn't really supposed
to get out I I went straight to the
hospital like at halftime of that you
know of that game which I was all kind
of in a bit of shock in that moment I
didn't really know what was going on I
was watching the game and just watching
anxiously just waiting for that final
whistle and once it went off the
emotions were were massive for me it was
a huge win for our country just a really
proud moment obviously you can see my
emotions there but I'm so curious the
photo wasn't supposed to go out you were
sending it to what friends teammates
family I think I just put that on one of
my like I don't know private stories or
something and it yeah it got out
somewhere but I don't really know the
whole story